Hi.
I'm Ricardo.
I work on the Google Play team.
I'm going to tell you
about all the tools
available in the
Developer Console
to help you build high
quality apps for Google Play,
from tips in the
publishing process,
to how to make the best
of the data reporting
available to you.
Let's start from the basics--
targeting the right audience.
First, it's a good idea to
do a bit of market research
and assess your target audience.
Understand and what and what
versions and screen sizes
you want to target.
If you go to
developer.android.com
and search for dashboards,
you can get relevant graphs
to show you which versions
you would want to support.
You're likely to get the best
result, if you design your app
to work on tablets
from the start.
The increased screen
area on tablets
gives you more
possibilities and allows
for more engagement
with the user, which
can mean increased usage as
well as more monetization
opportunities.
If you're building a
game, make sure you
choose the right category
among the 18 new game
categories recently
added in Google Play.
After sorting out the
general outline and placement
of your app, it's time
to start building it.
But don't wait until
your app is 100%
finished before
showing it to people.
We have designed
beta testing to help
you get user feedback
as early as possible.
Before your app is ready
to be seen by the world,
you can distribute it to a
group of users you select.
We call this alpha
and beta test groups.
If you don't yet have a
production version of your app,
your app will be
invisible in Google Play,
except to the
testers you choose.
If you're using Google
Play Games Services,
you can use the alpha
and beta testing
to test your game
services as well.
You can use Google groups or
Google+ communities to indicate
which users you want to be able
to access the test versions
of your apps.
You can set a what's new field
for each version of your app,
including the ones for testers.
And this is really useful
to tell your testers what's
new in the alpha and
beta versions they
are about to receive.
Each user will need to opt in
to be a tester for each app
and unload the app of course.
To aid users in doing so, many
developers create a little web
page with a set of
instructions that they send out
to their testers, or mention
it in their group or Google+
community.
Now that your alpha and
beta test is in progress.
It's good to know that users
who are alpha or beta testers
cannot leave reviews
for your app.
In this way, you can
protect against leaks
about your secret app
or harm to your ratings
if you're beta version
still has some bugs.
However, you can still see crash
reports, optimization tapes,
and statistics in the
Developer Console.
And we explicitly
mark out results
that pertain to your
alpha or beta test.
So for example, you can quickly
isolate all application crashes
that your beta testers
are experiencing.
Your beta testers are
great for identifying
bugs and the usability problems.
But keep in mind, they are
not a representative sample
of your target user population.
Once your app is looking
good to your beta testers,
and it has been through a full
round of testing on your side,
it's time to publish.
Once your app is
published to all users,
you will have some options when
you roll out your next updates.
Here at Google.
We want to be sure that
everything goes well when we
roll out new
version of our apps.
And we know that you do as well.
For this, we design
staged rollouts.
You can rollout
updates of your app
to just a percentage
of your users, like 5%,
and then crank it
up to 100% when
you can see that the
reviews are still good,
and there are no
problems on the horizon.
Don't panic, if you realize that
you rolled out a bad version
while a staged rollout
is still in progress.
Spin up a bug fix and
publish a new version.
Your fix will go out to the
users who have the bad one,
and you can resume the rollout.
Now that I covered the
publishing process, let's focus
on monitoring how
your app is doing.
Here at Google we think
that the developers do best
when they have lots of insights
into their users and app
performance.
Most successful
developers tell us
that they log into
the Developer Console
every day to check on
their statistics, reviews,
and optimization tips.
Here's an overview of
some of the types of data
that is offered in
the Developer Console
that we think more developers
should be looking at.
Starting from the
basics, most of you
know that you can see
installs and the uninstalls
over time in the
Developer Console.
In addition to that, if you
just go to the statistics page,
you can see how your app ratings
have changed over time, crash
trends and if you link
your Developer Console
account with Google Analytics,
data about your active users,
and their engagement
with your app.
Be sure to click on
app version to make
sure you compare your new
versions against the older
ones.
Also use the CSV exports to
download the full data set
beyond the first top 10 values.
If you're a game developer
and you use Google Play Games
Services in your app, you can
monitor your game performance
and key player metrics using
the new game stats module
that we just launched
a few weeks ago.
Crashes can be a major problem.
They make users unhappy
and dissatisfied.
They can result in
bad reviews and users
uninstalling your
app in frustration.
So we have spent time making
the crash reporting feature
in the Developer
Console even better.
You can check on your beta
test and your stage rollout
by filtering your
crashes by version.
You can also see how
these crashes break
down across different
devices and Android versions
to make it easier to track
down what's going wrong
or why users on a certain
device are complaining.
If you develop a native code,
we have improved the reporting
and presentation, specifically
for native crashes,
with better clustering
of similar crashes
and summarizing of
relevant information.
Also, remember that we
collect crashes in real time,
so you can monitor your
staged rollout or beta version
minutes after publishing it.
Finally, optimization
tapes show you new ways
that you can improve, tailored
to your own apps and users.
From adding translations,
making sure your app works well
on tablets and ensuring
your app is using the latest
versions of the Google
services you integrate with.
We also help you
out with alerts,
letting you know if there's been
a big change in your installs,
uninstalls, ratings, or crashes.
With alerts, you can
trust Google to alert you
whenever a relevant
event occurs.
So you can focus on
building your app.
We just added the ability to
get these alerts over e-mail.
So make sure you subscribe
to this new service
from the setting section
of the Developer Console.
To summarize, let me remind you
the core aspects in building
a quality app-- research and
identify your target audience,
collect early feedback
by your beta testers
while development is
still in progress,
do risk-free releases
with stage rollouts,
and keep optimizing
your app with the data
that Google Play makes
available to you.
Now get cracking.